in this video we'll be talking about the
nerve injury their types and Valerian
degeneration this is a high yield video
for USMLE step 1.
we have all experienced some kind of
nerve injuries during our life for
example maybe you have cut your hands
with a sharp knife that has cut the or
resected the nerve terminals in your
hand or sometimes there might be a
bigger accident which lead to a nerve
injury so nerve injury can happen in the
central nervous system that means the
brain and the spinal cord are also in
the peripheral nervous system
it turns out that peripheral nervous
system injury it is much more reversible
so the repair is pretty quick and it
could rev it could be revived
now the CNS injury is more severe
once it is
injured the neurons could not repair it
efficiently and eventually the Fate is
death of these neuron
still it's unclear that why the central
nervous system neurons are more
vulnerable towards nerve injury
in this video we try to appreciate the
different types of nerve injury and the
molecular mechanism behind that
in order to understand we have to
understand uh
Nerf bundle so here we can see a nerve
bundle which is covered by epineurium
then if you pull up each fascicles we
would see it it is comprised of several
nerve terminals or the axons
then it is covered with perineurium and
each of these axons are further covered
by endoneurium it would be important to
understand these structures while we
talk about the degeneration or the
injury process
so the first type of injury is
neuropraxia so in this case there is a
compression of the nerve in this case
the entire myelin sheath is there but
it's just compressed at a particular
point it's a reversible injury that
means it can be treated quickly one live
example is due to a sleeping posture you
might have sensed that tingling
sensation in your hand in the middle of
the night right that is exactly an
example of neuropraxia but in real life
scenario this is the most mild form of
injury you can expect
some injuries might be severe for
example
you fail from a bike or you have
undergone some kind of accident
in these kind of situations there could
be injuries which are known as
axonotomasis in this case the axon is
degraded or injured as a along with the
axon the myelin sheath is also vanished
so this is more severe compared to
neuropraxia we can see those two
situations side by side here first of
all the axon is damaged second of all
the myelin Shear is damaged but the
outer coat the epineurium is okay
there is another type known as
neurotomasis where axon is lost myelin
is lost and the endoneurium is also lost
note that in axon automation the
endonurium is still intact
now in case of axon injury for example
axon automation
eventually
the injured part of the nerve terminal
the axon and the synaptic terminal
degrades and degenerates over time this
is known as Valerian degeneration and
this is named after the discoverer
himself
so Valerian degeneration leads to
disintegration of the cytoskeleton at
the injured side mitochondrial swelling
and axonal fragmentation eventually it
would lead to the death of that neuron
Valerian degeneration was originally
defined as a degeneration of axon that
takes place from the distal part of an
injury
all the molecular mechanism can be
understood with mouse models or fly
models or many other animal models one
such animal model was wlds Valerian
degeneration slow mutant in this case
post injury
the degeneration happens slowly so this
is a normal
injury induced degeneration model so
where post injury the overall axon would
disintegrate and eventually the neuron
would die this depth process is known as
Valerian degeneration which is separate
from caspase-mediated death
now in case of wild s mutation the
mutants show a slower degeneration of
these injured nerve terminal
so that tells us this could be one of
the molecule that could be targeted or
that could be drugged to slow down this
kind of injury process
and presence of this molecule might lead
to this kind of injury so what is wild s
now let's talk about that
it turns out in that mutant there is one
particular enzyme which is known as
nmnat in a moment it would be clear what
this enzyme does is
targeted towards the axon it's kind of
like a stable version which is targeted
toward bags on in general case this
enzyme is having a very small Half-Life
and it has to be there in the nerve
terminal for proper functioning of the
neuron so what function does it perform
so this catalyzes the conversion of
mononuclei nucleotide into dinucleotide
or NAD it generates NAD
now for any neuron for all the synaptic
release or anything you need
ATP and NAD Works in this process to
eventually generate ATP in the nerve
terminals
so nmn get converted nmn is converted
into NAD with the help of the
nmnat2 enzyme
and eventually the energy is used in the
electron transport chain right and that
eventually generates ATP
now the Soma derived NM Nat can
eventually be transported along the
microtubules to the nerve terminal when
there is a an eventually in the synapse
it would be used to generate NAD and
this is a crucial process this process
this molecular process is abrogated when
there is a axonal injury so even if the
nmna2 is produced it can never be
transported into the end because already
there is a massive breakage of the Axon
and ultimately that lead to low level of
NAD or increased or accumulated level of
nmn it turns out the increased
concentration of nmn leads to several
toxicity
so what is that
so increased level of nmn actually
activates molecule which triggers the
degeneration
and in wlds what happens is there is a
stable and axonally targeted in a minute
T that means it is not always required
to transport this particular enzyme to
the axon once it is transported it stays
for pretty long generally the half-life
is very low but in this particular
mutant the half-life was not so low
that's why the degeneration was even
slower even after the injury
so now this is the normal normal
situation a wireless mutation which lead
to a stable an immunity leads to a slow
degeneration also the enzyme that can
inhibit or block the biosynthesis of
namp PT which is required for nmen
biogenesis
that can also slow the processes can
mimic or Shadow the overall phenotype of
wild days all these evidences suggest us
that nmn level in the axon or axonal
terminal is super important for Valerian
degeneration later on there are
discovery of several other mutants in
mice and in drosophila known as sarm1
this is kind of like an Executor
molecule in this entire degeneration
process this is kind of like a cleaved
caspase 3 analogous to please clipped
caspase three they have no similarity in
terms of their function but this is a
this particular molecule plays an
executed role someone mutant just like
world wild s shows slower degeneration
process that tells us without this
molecule degeneration would be much
slower and when this molecule is present
it the degeneration is five times faster
that means this is another potential
drug Target to slow down axonal injury
and injury-induced degeneration
so this is the overall working model
there could be disrupted delivery of
nmna T2 to the axonal terminals enemy T2
can be degraded by ubiquitinization or
there could be rapid turnover of nm2
with the help of mapkin is signaling all
these things lead to a reduction or a
loss of NM nat2 enzyme
that means nmn would be eventually
accumulated in the nerve terminals
So eventually NAD would not be produced
and Psalm 1 would be activated that
alter activation of Psalm 1 altered the
neuronal calcium homeostasis and
elevated level of calcium lead to kalpin
activation which eventually lead to
degradation of the damaged segment and
this is how the Valerian degeneration
takes place so I hope you get an
overview of the mechanisms underlying
Valerian degeneration it's bit
complicated but we at least understand
two important players in this process
one is nmn and another is the executor
molecule someone
now these
proteins nmna2
a and its mRNA is reduced in the brains
of patient with Alzheimer's disease
and no wonder Alzheimer's patients shows
a high level of neurodegeneration
also genome-wide Association studies has
found out that Psalm 1 Locus was
associated with hematopic lateral
sclerosis
similarly NM n82 loss was found in fetal
echinacea syndrome
so all these molecular players are found
to be mutated in various
neurodegenerative disease
and that brings out their importance as
an important molecular player and
druggable target
for these particular disease context
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a quick Thumb Thumbs
Up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can follow us on Instagram
or Facebook
you can contribute using paytm PayPal or
UPI see you in next video